[Music]
hey guys help me fight the techno core
by liking this video it's the only way
the youtube algorithm really notices my
content thanks guys the hyperion cantos
begins hundreds of years in our future
humankind at this time inhabits hundreds
of worlds many of which are connected by
firecaster technology which allows for
instantaneous travel between planets
many science fiction series involving
space-faring human civilization often
depict the earth as having been
destroyed long ago or lost within the
mists of time
this is true in the hyperion cantos as
well but with some twists and turns
earth had long since vanished after the
event known as the big mistake
in the first century after the big
mistake gia was mortally injured but
slow in the dying the devastation was
great during the bad times
and these came more often in precisely
plotted spasms shorter remissions more
terrible consequences after each attack
but the earth abided and repaired itself
as best it could
the big mistake was an experiment gone
wrong a team of scientists in the
ukraine had created a black hole which
they could not control over the course
of the next century it was said to have
devoured the earth entirely
people still lived on earth during the
bad times but most left during the
hajira the great exodus from the planet
but some stubborn humans never left the
earth even as it was dying
the character martin silenus who is one
of the seven pilgrims that showed up at
the beginning of the first book in the
hyperion cantos was born on earth
sometime after the big mistake
his family had been very rich so they
had many of the comforts that would have
not been allotted to the vast majority
living on earth during those times
about every 10 months the earth would go
into spasms as the black hole devoured
its core
these caused violent global earthquakes
though it was mainly believed that it
had been the arrogance of mankind that
caused the accident
it was also known that a computer error
had caused the black hole to become
unstable so some speculated that the
ai's involvement with the experiment at
the time had intentionally caused it to
go south this is actually confirmed in
the book fall of hyperion the big
mistake had been no mistake at all
the big mistake of 38 had been no
mistake the death of old earth had been
deliberate planned by elements of the
technocore and their human counterparts
and the fledgling government of the
hegemony the hajjara had been planned in
detail decades before the runaway black
hole had accidentally been plunged into
the heart of the old earth
the lions and tigers and bears was the
name given to the mysterious and
powerful beings which inhabited the void
which binds the realm which connects all
time and space
their name is a direct reference to the
1937 movie adaptation of the wonderful
wizard of oz by l frank baum when
considering what could be waiting for
them in the dark forest the tin man
remarks that there may be lions and
tigers and bears
the lions and tigers and bears are
merely a representative for the dark
things that could be potentially out
there hiding beyond sight it is also
revealed in the fall of hyperion that
unlike previously believed the earth had
not been actually destroyed after all it
had been moved by the lions tigers and
bears
earth spasmed and shook but did not die
the ultimates and volatiles insisted
that we move it where none of humankind
would find it so we did to the magellan
cloud where you find it now
the techno core during their
explorations of the void which binds
first encountered the beings they
referred to as the lions and tigers and
bears
the consciousness of these beings seemed
to reside fully within the void which
binds but they were also supposedly
creatures of both synthetic and organic
composition
whether or not they had physical bodies
is never confirmed one way or the other
there is a bit more to discuss
concerning the void which vines so we
will discuss that in another video the
lions tigers and bears were beings of
empathy and they acted in opposition to
the technocore who were beings who
lacked empathy entirely though the
volatiles of the techno corps had
already set the destruction of the earth
in motion the lions tigers and bears the
masters of the void which binds
teleported the earth
to humanity it looked as though the
world had been finally swallowed by the
black hole
the lions tigers and bears have their
own reason for saving the earth which we
will discuss later in another video as
well
thanks for watching guys make sure you
like and subscribe for more quinn's
ideas